desperate to come to the home of
football and safety these afghan female
players part of a youth development team
have waited weeks finally confirmation
their uk visas will be granted they've
called it a life-saving decision we were
going to a school and a university but
after taking over our country by
tallahan everything was stopped
everything was destroyed and
we were not able to play football
anymore and go to schools and
universities anymore everything was so
hard for us and we get to the pakistan
with a really hard situation
last month the team escaped into
neighbouring pakistan these pictures
give an idea of their terrifying weight
at the border that was so horrible that
was so scary for us because we were all
football players and we hide over and
they they can't identify us and
we pass
border by covering up and
veering bokras
they've now spent almost three weeks in
a hotel in lahore anxiously awaiting
this decision now confirmed by the home
office in a statement it said we are
working to finalize visas to the afghan
women's development team and look
forward to welcoming them to the uk
shortly the government is committed to
doing all it can to support those most
in need including vulnerable women and
girls
another group of young female afghan
players last week found a home in
portugal they've told reporters they
finally feel free to play football once
again we've got some universities that
want to help them we've got some premier
league clubs
that are willing to give some coaching
and the goal is for them to win some
trophies and
we're going to try and do that for them
in early september the taliban announced
it was banning women from all sports
sports women in the country have been in
hiding ever since
former afghan national footballer
khalida popel now resident in denmark
knows how difficult that must be
unfortunately taliban in a very first
weeks of
the empowerment and they announced that
there they don't see sport as something
necessary for women and girls it is
against islamic
law and it's against the sharia law that
they are following for the young players
they just can't wait to get here we were
so happy we're so excited and
we feel that
we can have another chance for life and
for playing football harriet hadfield
sky news